what is the area of improvement you
think Jared golf needs to make here is
coach you're in his year he's he no you
know I mean you're obviously attached at
the hip what is it experience is it just
that sort of that's sort of fire where
he just feels it yeah owns it like
running for that first down and to that
big but that wrapped it up yeah I mean
that moment where golf is da man yeah
does he need that smell I think he's
already the man you know I think he's
had a lot of moments his player you know
his teammates believe in him as coaches
believe in them and you know I think
it's just continuing to do what you do
at a higher level it's can I continue to
make great decisions can I throw us at
with accuracy in anticipation and I
think the thing that was great about him
really from the first year we were
together to last year the ownership you
know we talked about the quarterback
being an extension of the coaching staff
rich and I think he did that and I think
it's let's take the next step this year
where we've gotten you know an inventory
of defensive structures and games that
you've played now put that in the memory
bank so that when you see these similar
types of looks you say I've been here
before I know what types of play calls
to expect from Sean where we're really
attached at the hip like you mentioned
so it's really just taking the next
steps you know in terms of just the
maturity and gaining that experience and
that goes the same thing for me as well
and that's what's so unique about you
know the relationship that Jared and I
have is we're going through a lot of
them the maturity if you will on kind of
the growing pains but but we sure have
had a lot of good times over these first
couple years and expect to have many
more if we approach it the right way for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on be our live or download the Rich
Eisen show app